[Music]
you didn't talk all game
you're not listening to your teammates
so you're not paying attention you guys
just need to focus way more for next
game
because this game was all on you guys
the coaching staff doesn't want to work
with you
um they feel like it's a really
unprofessional unhealthy work
environment by gbm lassandra
though into the front line goes lower
low a triple kill for zardoc
killing everybody with a quadrikill so i
checked out all 36 minutes of this game
i don't think that's accurate at all
logo
i mean i made it i made them i take
criticism just fine when it's actual
criticism
the main problem was obviously me
there's only one person that changed so
uh watching them go to worlds in general
is obviously really
saddening and that was like probably my
lowest point after a certain amount of
times when a player keeps asking they
get traded after each split somebody's
going to be like
why is he not sticking on one team this
is the end of the series
and the end of the line for dignitas as
tsm
will make swift work of dignitas with a
3-0 victory
and will move on to the next round of
playoffs
[Music]
despite being only 22 dardoch has been
on so many nalcs teams that it's easier
to remember which rosters he hasn't been
a part of
and the reason why he's jumped from team
to team doesn't actually have very much
to do with his skill as a player
it's just like thing with dardoch is
when he's when things get bad
there's no getting better it just all
goes downhill after that
dardoch's achilles heel has always been
his attitude
moving back move backwards okay you guys
like
don't listen to the team fight calls at
all actually it's actually quite
astonishing
oh god bless dardoch isn't my team i
don't care if he's getting
[ __ ] annoying to play with as far
back as 2014 dardoch had a pretty
bad reputation i wouldn't really let
people get words in
or you know speak their opinion or even
like reply to what i had to say it was
just like i want you to do this
and if you don't there's going to be a
problem he got banned for being toxic
for leaving for being the kind of player
you never
want to see on your team in solo queue
but he was good enough to go
pro which meant his attitude only really
caught up with him when he joined team
liquid
in 2016. tarlock gets one traitor back
in by gbm lassandra is logo
into the front line goes lower low a
triple kill for
dardoch killing everybody with a quadra
kill
while other players would try to take
advantage of being part of an enormous
established org like team liquid darnoch
made
different choices okay i agree look i'm
agreeing with you i disappeared
for 100 i think it's absolutely [ __ ]
everything coming out of his mouth came
from the hospital you can't take
criticism at all
i take criticism just fine when it's
actual criticism he's allegedly volatile
relationship with his teammates
coaches and even team liquid management
became a hot topic of discussion in the
league community
after he was suspended for what team
liquid called behavioral issues and
insubordination coaching staff doesn't
want to work with you
um they feel like it's a really
unprofessional unhealthy work
environment
obviously from a business standpoint i
am investing a ton of money so it's
extremely costly for me
to run a business where i'm investing
into things and then they want to just
like quit because
of the environment that's being created
and dardoch's departure from team liquid
in november 2016
was just the first of many you didn't
talk all game
you're not listening to your teammates
so you're not paying attention you guys
just need to focus way more for next
game
because this game was all on you guys
bottom despite being one of the best
junglers north america has ever produced
dardoch has never seemed to be able to
get along with his teammates
and that's crippled his career with
immortals
certainly a lot of the games we won last
split were dardoch going off and
carrying
but a big reason why he needed to be the
one to go off and carry is because
he wasn't the best fit for our team
dynamic and that did have a negative
impact on a lot of the other players
within the team i do think he's a really
good player
but as time goes on it was like kind of
out of the game stuff that we didn't
like as a team match him
and he didn't really understand why we
were doing like certain things
so i just think like overall we weren't
a really good fit
dardoch was even given another chance on
team liquid
but that ended up being more of the same
sorry to everybody that i've
caused emotional pain to or mental
strain um
sorry for making you know so many
coaches stressed about me and what teams
can do the next day in practice because
i can't act right
despite his claims that he was a changed
man dardoch's time with echo fox and
optic gaming both
ended in a pretty similar way my
line of bad behavior has gone on for so
long and my
line of good behavior is not as long so
i do understand the aspect of having to
prove yourself but i think at this
point it's a little tired but dardoch
kept getting signed to more
teams and it made a lot of people ask
why was this
toxic team wrecker getting a shot on so
many rosters
and they kind of told me that he had
blown up here had problems here problems
with teammates
i said well let's bring him in and talk
to him let's interview him came in mixed
me on his face sat down and crossed his
legs
and i was like something's not quite
adding up
and i said why is everybody scared of
you and he goes i just want to win
they're not doing what i think it takes
to win i'll tell them
i respect that i'm the same way
[Music]
level nine versus eight actually got a
lot of xp on this eve seal
and forcing that down it's very very low
hp and the eight trucks can you get the
chase
he goes in for the flash eq dardoch solo
kills h
that's the ultimate down from gate he
uses the quickness out of vision which
beats him get in after that cooldown
goes off and they are just going to
obliterate counter logic gaming
the horn horn comes through that's
tuesday's steal he says why you're
hitting yourself
and it's going to be a lorem saying
that's fine i didn't even feel it
as they go back into the fight tuesday
goes down that's a triple kill
coming in for dardoch as he just goes
off on kane
unlucky here shotgun gonna find jensen
the rooster to come back through the
here comes the engage and dardoch
doesn't want to be part of this
oh my gosh just kidding takes one down
blocks the shot starduck is amazing
double kill comes through they're going
to trade his life for that kill that was
actually immaculate
but dardoch getting thrown around from
team to team and
never really finding his place made a
lot of fans lose hope
but the end of 2019 looked to be the
start of a new chapter
in dardoch's life he joined tsm as their
new jungler stunts there on the front
line going to be taken low
however the gargoyle stone plate will
keep him healthy enough bullet time goes
out but bio frost walks out of the way
stun
is going to be killed by bjergsen
biofrost continues to hide
off grabs a lot of damage a lot of cc
and that's all they
needed a double kill for the jungler a
triple kill
and an ace for tsm tsm looked like
dardoch's last chance
if things didn't work out there his
career could have been over
so let's talk about this jungle matchup
dardak once again has
a very storied history in the lcs a
contentious one
to say the least but he's now found a
home on tsm
is this the team to allow him to rise to
hit that kind of stardom stat it has to
be
from the outside looking in it seemed
like dardoch had finally seen the error
of his ways
honestly the biggest worry that most
people had when tsm
signed dardoch this year in one of the
you know most controversial i guess
signings was mainly based on attitude
that people had heard
about him you know being difficult to
work with or
um you know not being the greatest
communicator in game
honestly i have heard nothing negative
about dardoch
since joining tsm i think that he has
done a very good job
turning around that story that has
followed him but behind the scenes
everything was going wrong picking for
this guy was maybe a mistake
[Music]
even though publicly it looked like
dardoch was a reformed man
that phone call made it seem like behind
the scenes things were the same as they
always were dardoch has been a
troublesome part of the tsm roster from
the start in the first few weeks of
practice there was a big blow-up from
dardoch and talks were had
and tsm and dardoch both thought things
would get better but throughout the
season
there has been constant problems and the
sport psych has been working directly
within way more so than any other player
and the results have been pretty
middling but dardoch still had the
potential
he still could have been the best
jungler in north america
even if he was being kicked off a team
after just one split
again i was being pushed towards a style
i didn't agree with and i didn't think
it was good
and i should have had the confidence in
myself and my own ability to be like no
i think this is good i'm going to
continue to play these
these characters or this way or whatever
the case may be
right as for how tsm handled this whole
thing well dardoch doesn't see it as
much of a tragedy
it's embarrassing sure but this isn't
his first rodeo
it wasn't like catastrophic right not
like
everybody's throwing out the word like
career ending or things like that but
to be frank like if your career's in
that point to begin with where people
are not interested in you then
you know one leak or somebody's saying
something like that isn't necessarily
going to be the tipping point of
you know my career's downfall or
something like that and of course
stardock's phenomenal skills meant there
was a new team
ready and lined up to give him a shot as
soon as he was done with tsm
fight onto viper galley over the top
he's gonna oh to get rid of the knock up
a lot of damage comes in the hook gonna
pull him out
is there enough of a fight here because
the arrows coming in it stuns the mid
laner fighter gets into the shield
and hoonie's going to drop so will the
mid laner yet again dignitas winning a
fight
in in for sanskaran yes he's going to
drop
a triple kill in for dardoch dignitas
will not be stopped honestly i'm very
happy to be here i won't lie
uh my spring while it didn't go how i
wanted it to or how i expected it to
it went extremely poorly right so i
wasn't happy with it and i was very much
excited to have an opportunity to get
out of that
that team i was on so yeah i'm very
excited to be here and i'm very happy to
be on dig
despite dardoch's best efforts dignitas
didn't do that great
ultimately falling to tsm in the
playoffs this is the
end of the series and the end of the
line
for dignitas as tsm will make swift work
of dignitas with a 3-0 victory
and will move on to the next round of
playoffs his contract with dignitas
expires in november so
his future with the team is far from
certain but for the most part
nothing came out this split about his
attitude or toxicity
it seemed like at long last someone
finally found a way to funnel his fiery
passion to the game
in the right direction away from his
teammates just in general nowadays i try
to
stay away from you know not necessarily
expressing myself
but just you know giving 110
for what i really think unless i'm very
very
very passionate about it whether dardoch
is truly reformed remains to be seen
but the fans are rooting for him they
want to see him
finally realize his potential finally
find that balance between passion and
humility that could make him great
that could let him take his place among
the league's finest
but his time may be running out there
are only so many teams he hasn't joined
left
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages